quand on aime on ne compte pas les
risques non plus semble-t-il pour donald
je pense que nous allons faire une
petite surprise à ses formidables
patriotes qui sont dehors depuis
longtemps avec des drapeaux trump et qui
aime notre pays
quand je voi enthousiasme que sans doute
personne d'autre n'a jamais connu cet
enthousiasme de personnes qui aiment
notre travail
je me dis que j'ai droit à plus d'
enthousiasme que n'importe qui d'autre
positif au kobus 19 hospitalisé pendant
plusieurs jours le président américain
n'a rien trouvé de mieux que de sortir
de l'hôpital militaire de walter reed à
près de washington et cela pour saluer
ses partisans massés devant
l'établissement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une sortie qui a suscité de vives
critiques puisque jugé trop risqué pour
les agents de la protection du chef
d'état américain âgé de 74 ans il faut
que chaque personne présente dans le
véhicule pendant cette sortie
présidentielle complètement inutiles
soient placés en quarantaine pendant 14
jours ils peuvent tomber malades ils
peuvent mourir au du théâtre politique
un théâtre voulue par trump qui met leur
vie en danger
c'est de la folie l'irresponsabilité de
trump semble sans fin faire conduire ces
agents des services secrets avec un
patient covit 19 qui plus est avec des
fenêtres fermées les expose inutilement
à un risque d'infection
et pourquoi un coup de pub c'est honteux
ces agents risquent déjà leur vie chaque
jour un coup de pied en pleine campagne
électorale
rien de très étonnant à moins d'un mois
du scrutin présidentiel cette
contamination coville 19 pourrait en
effet coûté sa réélection à donald trump
réélire à un candidat
inconscients du danger n'est pas
forcément la qualité première
recherché par les électeurs même si sa
personnalité atypique l'a mené à la
victoire en 2016 face à hillary clinton
depuis qu'il a été testé positif celui
qui est toujours locataire de la maison
blanche se veut rassurant je vais bien
je pense
merci à tous je vous aime après avoir
évoqué de légers symptômes
le médecin de la maison blanche a
finalement admis que l'état initial de
donald trump était plus grave que ceux
qui a officiellement été annoncée du
jeudi soir ou vendredi matin quand j'ai
quitté son chevet
le président allait bien avec seulement
des symptômes bénins et un taux
d'oxygène proche de 100 vendredi soir
quand je suis retourné à son chevet il
avait une forte fièvre et sa saturation
en oxygène était tombé transitoirement
au dessous de 94 % iphone personnes
jusqu'à ce jour pourquoi avez vous été
aussi réticents à révéler que le
président avait reçu de l'oxygène
c'est une bonne question j'essayais de
refléter l'attitude optimiste de
l'équipe du président ainsi que
l'évolution de la maladie
je ne voulais donner aucune information
susceptible de laisser supposer que la
maladie aller dans une autre direction
et ce faisant nous avons essayé de
cacher quelque chose qui n'était pas
nécessairement avéré une communication
vous l'aurez compris brouillonne sur
l'état de santé de donald trump cette
contamination kobe 19 contrarie sa
stratégie qui consistait le plus
possible à passer sous silence sa
gestion de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui le président américain
semble avoir reçu une leçon qu'ils
qualifient d' intéressante
j'ai beaucoup appris sur le coup vide je
les ai appris en faisant l'expérience
moi même c'est l'école de la vie c'est
pas l'école dans les livres je les fais
j'ai compris c'est très intéressant je
vous expliquerai tout ça des
explications attendues au tournant par
de nombreux américains est les etats
unis pays le plus touché du monde par le
kobe 19 comptabilise plus de 7 millions
600 mille cas de contamination et plus
de 200000 morts